and I think the greatest threat and the
greatest concern certainly for the
Royals is the force coming autobiography
which is of course caused a lot of
consternation in Royal circles a lot of
concern amongst senior Royal sources and
and Palisades because quite simply they
don't know what to expect Well turns out
they had reason to be concerned because
according to a new report from the
guardian which has obtained an excerpt
from Prince Harry's upcoming tell-all
Memoir spare the Duke of Sussex claims
his older brother William physically
attacked him after the two got into an
argument over Harry's wife Meghan Markle
Harry has taken a 35 million Advance
that's not going to be for Harry talking
about his philanthropic work that's
going to be the inside story of being
born the spare in the excerpt Harry
describes an alleged confrontation at
his London home in 2019. he claims his
brother called Megan difficult rude and
abrasive something Harry called a quote
parroting of the press narrative about
his wife what started off as a
conversation quickly turned into a
shouting match a similar situation to
the one Harry detailed in his recent
Netflix docu-series Harry and Megan it
was terrifying to have my brother scream
and shouts at me and my father say
things that just simply went true and my
grandmother you know quietly sit there
and sort of take it all in according to
Harry he tried to calm his brother down
and offered him a glass of water quote
he set down the water called me another
name then came at me it all happened so
fast so very fast he grabbed me by the
collar ripping my necklace and he
knocked me to the floor Harry alleges
that he landed on the dog's food bowl
which cracked and cut into his back
quote I lay there for a moment dazed
then got to my feet and told him to get
out Harry claims William urged him to
hit back but he refused so William left
but later returned looking regretful and
apologize before asking Harry to not
tell Megan about the fight
and while Harry says he didn't
immediately share the incident with his
wife Megan noticed the scrapes and
bruises which forced him to tell her
about the alleged attack her response he
says she wasn't surprised and wasn't
angry she was just terribly sad I think
everyone wants to see a repair in the
Riff because it doesn't do anyone any
good to have this rift at the heart of
the House of Windsor they feel as though
it's better to keep us somehow as the
villains in anticipation of Spears
release on January 10th Harry is giving
two interviews both airing on Sunday one
to ITV and another to Anderson Cooper on
60 Minutes
teasers for both conversations were
released earlier this week revealing
Harry wants to have both his brother and
his father King Charles III back in his
life despite their strained
relationships but he says his family
prefers to hold on to the narrative that
he and Megan are the ones in the wrong
they've shown absolutely no willingness
to reconcile I would like to get my
father back I would like to have my
brother back
[Music]
thank you